E aí
se você se sente bonita
se você se sente sensual
e tem uma vez que eu me questionei sobre
isso logo depois de um ex-namorado falar
para mim que o motivo da gente não
transa mais é porque tava gorda
a guarda essa frase a gente volta lá ele
falou isso para mim eu imediatamente fui
para o espelho olhar e eu fiquei ali
olhando por um tempo tirando um retrato
mental meu usando o coração como câmera
a câmera é um instrumento que ensina a
gente ver sem a câmera você faz não é
minha é da dor que realmente ela não
retratista muito apreciada acho que
quando ela falou sobre isso ela queria
dizer debater sobre a diferença entre
ver o momento e capturar esse momento o
que leva a uma questão central da minha
profissão Como olhar
e naquele dia no espelho
e eu tinha uma questão que ninguém
conseguia me responder nem a dor o tia
como olhar para mim mesma e antes que
você pense que a leonina veio falar de
como elas catapultou de um
relacionamento abusivo etc o espalha
para vocês
hoje eu vim falar de amor
e outra coisa que a gente escuta muito
também é fotografia sobre contar
histórias mas eu te pergunto a senhora
de quem esse Isso é uma história de amor
tá contando ela quando o meu ex decidiu
falar aquilo para mim ele não tinha
percebido mas ele tinha decidido contar
a minha história do jeito dele do jeito
machista dele jeito machista e
gordofóbico' dele mas a verdade é que
quando eu me olhei no espelho naquele
dia eu não não me sentir bonita
e mesmo sabendo que eu era linda
a única tá fazendo mais importância para
emagrecer para tá bonita do que
simplesmente me ver bonita
e quem está contando essa história
e eu me lembrei de todas as vezes que eu
vi a uma foto antiga minha que no
momento que ela foi tirada eu não me
senti a sensual tia mil questões com meu
corpo com a Minha autoestima mais uma
hora depois eu vi a mesma foto e eu
pensava meu Deus que linda que eu tava
E isso se repetiu ano após ano todo ano
eu vi uma foto antiga minha e eu achava
que eu tava linda mas agora eu não
achava que eu tava bonita eu nunca tava
bonita no agora
se você se sente bonita agora
e ele perguntei de novo e eu me senti
e exausta eu cansei chega Mariana já deu
disso porque que tem que ser alterar
Tanto para você se gostaram agora
eu nunca chega o momento já reparou que
nunca chega o momento e quando chega
você nem aproveita direito precisa disso
de verdade precisa você não acha que tá
te imitando demais tem que ser alterar
tanto para se gostar
e quando eu comecei a fotografar eu fiz
primeiro ensaio sensual de uma amiga e
eu entendi tudo sobre aquele chamado eu
entendi que fotografando a sensualidade
das mulheres o projeção psicológica eu
ia resgatar a minha e eu tava muito
disposta a me sentir sensual de novo e
eu pensei é psicologia se eu vejo nela
significa que eu também tenho Então
vamos sagrado e claro né Depois que você
fotografa mais de 800 mulheres você
entende que tem questões que são de todo
mundo
as coisas que eu aprendi nesse processo
a interferir o menos possível porque no
ensaio fotográfico a história não é
minha a história dela
Oi e a gente está acostumado achar aqui
sensualidade tem hora para aparecer tem
tamanho de corpo então de voz mas eu não
acredito nisso na minha sensação a
sensualidade ela hesa ela é o perfume da
Alma ela exala naturalmente quando eu tô
sendo muito eu
É mas aqui incentivam a gente a vida
toda né as e tanta coisa menos quem a
gente realmente já
é difícil que é né pintar cabelo um
padrão de beleza Mundial que muitas
vezes não tem nada a ver com meu tem
nada a ver com a minha natureza que toda
vez que o caminho nessa direção eu me
fira emocionalmente eu fui na minha
fisiologia também
é mas eu entendi que quando eu passo a
ser a minha própria referência de beleza
a bancar minha diferença eu me torno a
pessoa mais sexy da mente mesma mensagem
de manhã não tem nada a ver com isso é
energia é magnético negócio
Oi e aí depois que eu entendi isso
entrou a técnica
a luz natural
e noventa porcento do tempo você vai se
ver botando a sua carinha linda no sol e
não através do lilás que você comprou
para virar blogueira na quarentena então
pelas que você tiver junta da sua
própria e se ilumina
os dois ambiente controlado
e eu prefiro fotografar as clientes na
casa dela às vezes mulheres na casa dela
porque eu percebi que quando você
conhece um ambiente a ponto de você
saber onde está a sua espátula favorita
só Caneca favorita porque não também se
familiarizar e se conhecer
e a ponto de você sentar e gostar da sua
cozinha que aparece quando você tenta
conheço a você como você conhece a sua
casa então de imagem gente já falei
quase não tem o que eu faço é real
samudes e corrigir problemas de luz
dando porque a gente sabe né o mundo não
é perfeito mas a gente vai
o Lux ó Sabe aquela calcinha seus
paranauês que você comprou mas você não
usou tá na gaveta porque ela é
desconfortável então no seu ensaio
sensual você também não não é de você
usar você não vai usar deixa na gaveta
eu reforço que é muito legal quando você
se sente confortável com a sua roupa
mesmo que seja um moletom tudo bem você
pode ser sexy de moletom e também se
você quiser você pode ser sexy nua não
precisa estar pelada para ser sensual
mas se você quiser se sinta livre a pose
tava na beleza já falei gente
é um segredo vou dizer agora não tem
pose não existe processual o que existe
é Você vivendo e sensual com você vive
por isso que eu incentivo também
atividade que você gosta de fazer desde
tá no ano uma fogueira ou tomar o seu
café o seu drinque na sua Caneca não só
taça favorita tudo bem que tomar o seu
café na sua taça e faz muito sucesso
é muito sucesso tipo muito
e é interessantíssimo você vê uma mulher
Contando um caso sendo ela sendo a
verdade dela por exemplo essa foto eu
fiz quando é eu tinha acabado de conta
para ela que eu ia dar um toque olha a
expressão que linda
Ah pois é então faz o teste pergunta
para alguém sobre a viagem mas legal que
ela fez na vida perguntas sobre o prato
mais gostoso que ela comeu pergunta isso
que você vai ver o espetáculo que vai
acontecer na sua frente a pessoa vai te
contar com uma alegria muito ciasta não
é verdade que é só dela tem coisa mais
sensual que alguém te contar uma
história de vida do jeito dela sendo ela
e envolvente é uma delícia assistir mas
ninguém te contou isso né eu sei que não
isso tá nas Entrelinhas Isso é o que
chamo de o entre que eu entendi que
quando você olha uma foto Onde você tá
no seu ambiente natural usando as suas
peças de roupas favorita sem pousar sem
luz de palco sem milagre sem alinhamento
Estelar e você olha para foto para sua
foto e você se conhece muito ali você
diz um sim para você
e para foto reflexo e alguma coisa muda
e o ensaio ele é composto por uma série
de clique e respiro um clique
e eu respiro clique respiro e a gente
acha que o clique é mais importante
porque ele é o produto material É o que
tem para postar no vídeo mais um é
consequência do outro e no meu trabalho
e eu gosto eu reforço aqui o respiro tem
muita força
é muita força no respiro e é isso que eu
amo o Henrique é esse momento de
navegação entre uma foto e outra onde
você acredita de verdade que tá tudo bem
sim e você Tá tudo bem Tá tudo bem você
quem você é agora é que a gente não tá
acostumado com isso né pelo contrário a
gente tá acostumada a achar que a julgar
a gente acostumada a julgar quem a gente
é
e a julgar quem a outra é
e já entrar nessa corrida que não tem
linha de chegada e aí nesse monte de
julgamento ser sensual acaba sendo mais
uma forma de opressão mais uma coisa que
eu tenho que modificar e mim para ser e
que eu tenho que modificar em mim para
só ser Quando é conveniente para o outro
e nessas de dar poder para o outro um
dia ele pode achar que pode mandar no
seu batom ou no seu decote ou falar que
o motivo da gente não transa mais é
porque eu tô gorda
E aí
é mas
e naquele dia do espelho
e quando me olhei
e eu decidi vasculhar aquele Campo
Minado de ressentimentos ligados à
beleza valorização pessoal abuso
emocional no relacionamento e tudo que
estava diretamente ligado a minha
auto-estima
e eu tirei a importância que eu dava
para opinião do outro do mundo
é a minha sensualidade me libertou ela
foi o divisor de águas na minha vida da
água Tu vai que eu quase não me via
refletida para transformação de isso em
essência e perfume
o que seria isso mal que me aqui a
fórmula secreta da Beleza não sei isso
isso de verdade você mas
é o que eu sei é que
e a sua sensualidade a sua natureza
e a sua diferença
O que é ser você
e agora
E aí
eu não falei que era uma história de
amor à